I am sitting here with the incredible
cartoonist cartoon editor for The New
Yorker Bob man cough word about
president of Hair Club for Men also a
peasant and totally natural the thing
that makes the New Yorker cartoon
experience so fascinating is you are
really an expert at figuring out like
this is a joke and this isn't a joke
most people go to audiences if you're a
stand-up yeah we went to you like Oz and
you would sit there you actually bought
some of my cartoons which was a huge
thrill yes I remember selling my first
one and then I got a text that it was in
the magazine I'm in New York yeah and I
left the house at like 11:30 in my
pajama bottoms of Ivy
buy the cartoon and find it was on page
69 thank you for that yeah I still brag
about being in The New Yorker and I have
a TV and we still regret it no we're
dudes cartoonists can we agree you you
you don't want somebody that can just do
one you want somebody that can do 10 a
week and be rejected week after week
after week after week it's not just
persistence persistence is it can be its
own type of madness but sort of what's
called grit where you sort of get the
feedback from it you don't personalize
you don't say hey man cops an I
can't believe you rejected it okay man
cop is an but maybe right guys
do look like chickens one time told me
my guys look like chicken I said you son
of a I didn't at the time I said
thank you sir thank you for your
audience do you mind if I show you some
homes I'm gonna tell you I am the
biggest fan of my own sense of humor I
think I laughed
and then you're dealing with the kiss of
death
so it's a scarecrow at a bar why would a
scarecrow be drinking the of it is
I love crows Niram my scarecrows not
fantastic if not way you don't even want
to go in it gently because the first
thing knocked it out you know we don't
want it we don't want to pile on here he
tried to develop a very distorted
Mannerist style mm-hmm that's it this is
so bad he must be doing it intentionally
that's right
so bad it's a choice it's a choice I
drew it with my choice oh man it's going
to be a problem so it's the dog in the
back and look at that cat like it's just
a colonoscopy
I didn't you'll get to a place where you
can validate your own parking spot
that's the one we bought yeah I was
gonna
getting tedious by the way I never you
know it's like seven it's from both of
us but that's a perfect party it's a
party you can't go wrong with a pirate
except you have so Bob you you started
the caption contest I did and earlier
today you tweeted this drawing by our
friend drew guilty and to have people
submit captions for it they have I
thought we could come up with the
perfect one because I mean two
professionals give it a try
how about how is it that were floating
in absolute nothingness forget me
holding you up it's terrifying that we
are in a void right now give me my gun
back Bob when I say this is a dream come
true I mean that very sincerely I am a
big admirer of your work and a respecter
of your taste the real did I not know
I'm a huge fan of your work and I plan
to watch the show now please